in the last video we set up a random
variable X which was defined as the
number of heads from flipping a fair
coin five times and then we figured out
the probability that our random variable
could take on the value zero one two
three four or five and just just
visualize that in this video we will
actually plot these and we got a sense
of this random variables probability
distribution so let's do that so let's
let's see maybe actually maybe I'll do
it like this so that we can so that we
can see the probabilities and actually I
can let me erase this business right
over here whoops that's not working let
me hear that might work let me erase
this real fast these little scribbles
that I had off-screen and then we can
actually plot the distribution all right
so the at one axis I'm going to put all
of the different outcomes so let me it
looks like a pretty straight line and
then this asked axis I'm going to plot
the probabilities and that looks like a
pretty straight line and let's see what
the probabilities are we have we have
let's see it's all going to be in terms
of 30 seconds and we get as high as 10
30 seconds so let's say this right over
here is that right over there is 10 30
seconds and 30 seconds half way up there
we have subt we have 2 5 30 seconds so
let's see that looks like about half
that right over there is 5 30 seconds
and then 1/32 would be about this it's 1
to see our split up 1 2 3 actually let
me do it a little bit 1 2 3 4 5 all
right so let's say this is 1/32 right
over here and our probabilities so this
right over here probability so this is
what the R and the values that the
random variable could take on so I'll
just make a little histogram here so X
equal
zero and then and the probability there
and actually since I want to do a
histogram it will look like this so let
me do a little bit different so right
here so X is equal to zero right there
the probability is 1/32 I can shade that
in now I have the probability that x
equals one x equals one is five thirty
Seconds so let me draw that
so five thirty seconds so put the bar
there so let me shade that in this right
over here is the probability that X is
equal to one that we get one what that
one exactly one out of the five flips
result in heads now we have the
probability x equals two x equals two is
ten thirty Seconds so that's going to
look like this
that's going to be look like this
alright my best attempt at hand drawing
it so somehow I like the aesthetics of
hand drawn things more sometimes if you
just get a computer to graph its I don't
know sometimes loses a little bit of its
personality alright so that right over
there is the probability that we get
that X that our random variable X is
equal to two then we have the
probability that x equals three which is
also ten thirty seconds so that is also
ten thirty seconds so let me draw that
this is also ten thirty seconds shade
this in I'm too dumb to dumb all right
I find this strangely therapeutic
alright so this is the probability that
X is equal to three now x equals four
that's five thirty seconds so we go back
right over here that's five thirty
seconds
so a that one in this right over here is
X is equal to four and then finally the
probability that x equals five is 1/32
again it's the same same level as this
right over here shade it in so this
right over here is a random variable X
equaling five and so when you visually
show this probability distribution it's
supporting realize this is a discrete
probability distribution this is a
discrete random variable it can only
take on a finite number of values
actually I should say it's a finite
discrete random variable you could have
something that takes on discrete values
but in theory it could take on you know
an infinite number of discrete values
you could just keep counting higher and
higher and higher but this is discrete
and that it's kind of these whole these
particular values it can't take on any
value in between and it's also finite it
can only take on x equals 0 x equals 1 x
equals 2 x equals 3 x equals 4 or x
equals 5 and you see when you plot it's
it's it's probability distribution this
discrete probability distribution you
have it you know it starts at 1/32 it
goes up and then it comes back down and
it has this symmetry and a distribution
like this this right over here
a discrete distribution like this we
call this a binomial distribution and
we'll talk in the future about why it's
called a binomial distribution but a big
clue actually I'll tell you why it's
called a binomial distribution is that
these probabilities you can get them
using binomial coefficients using
combinatorics in another video we'll
talk about especially when we talk about
the binomial theorem why we even call
those things binomial coefficients but
it's really based on taking powers of
binomials in algebra but this is a very
very very very important distribution
it's very important in statistics
because for a lot of a lot of discrete
processes one might assume that the
underlying distribution is a binomial
distribution and when we get further in
to fit into statistics we will we'll
talk why people do that now if you were
to if you were to have if you have much
more than 5 cases here if instead of
saying that the number
of heads for flipping a coin five times
you said X is equal to the number of
heads flipping a coin five million times
then you can imagine you'd have much
much you know the bars would get
narrower and narrower relative to the
whole hump and what it would start to do
it would start to approach something
that looks really something that looks
really like a bell curve
we do that in a color that you can see
better that I haven't used yet so it
would start to look so if you had more
and more of these if you had more and
more of these possibilities it's going
to start approaching what looks like a
bell curve and you've probably heard the
notion of a bell curve and the bell
curve is a normal distribution so if you
as one way to think about it is the
normal distribution is the probability
density function it's a continuous case
so the yellow one that we're approaching
a normal distribution and a normal
distribution and kind of the classical
sense is going to keep going on and on
normal distribution and it's related to
the binomial you know a lot of times in
statistics people will assume a normal
distribution because it's a-okay it's
the product of kind of an almost an
infinite number of random processes
happening here we're taking a coin we're
flipping it five times but if you
imagine kind of molecules interacting or
humans interacting you're saying oh
there's almost an infinite number of
interactions and then that's going to
result in a normal distribution which is
very very important in science and
statistics binomial distribution is the
discrete version of that and one little
point of notion you know these these are
where the distributions are this is
where they come from this is how they're
related if you kind of think about as
you get more and more trials your
binomial distribution is going to really
approach the normal distribution but
it's really important to think about
where these things come from and we'll
talk about it much more in statistics
because it is reasonable to assume an
underlying binomial distribution or a
normal distribution for a lot of
different types of processes but
sometimes it's not and you know even in
things like economics sometimes people
assume a normal distribution when when
it's actually much more likely that the
things on the ends are going to happen
which might lead to things like economic
crises or whatever else but anyway I
don't want to get off topic the whole
point here is just
appreciate hey you know we started with
this random variable the number of heads
from flipping a coin five times and we
plotted it and we were able to see we
were able to visualize this binomial
distribution and I'm kind of telling you
I haven't really shown you that if you
were to if you had many many more flips
and you defined the random variable in a
similar way then this then the this
histogram is going to look a lot this
bar chart it's going to look a lot more
like a bell curve and if you had
essentially an infinite number of them
you would start having a continuous
probability distribution or I should say
probability density function and that
would be that would get us closer to a
normal distribution